[Applaudissements]
donc avec temps dans un bar il vaut
quand toi il est le patron vers le bas
il fait si vous prenez du whisky le mec
lui c'est un whisky le ti bwa louise
pièce va pas trop il fait monsieur il
fait oui mais il faut payer dit bah
pourquoi il dit parce que vous avez pris
un risque et dinan monsieur vous me
l'avait offert ai dit comment ça vous a
fermé ce qu'il va dire oui vous me dis
qu'est-ce que vous prenez moi quand je
dis à quelqu'un qui est ce que vous
prenez
c'est que j'invite mes gars ben moi je
fais pas gaffe aux formulations y aller
mais c'est important monsieur voilà moi
j'ai cru s'est offert son genre est trop
de choses libre on bat hockey bien le
mec s'en va le lendemain il revient donc
le patron le voile reconnaît la danse a
dit rien le mec va au bar pour 1,9 casse
l'ofs
il nous avait un couteau pas trop lui je
vous ai rien dit il fait moins d'excusés
rakuto j'ai un couteau
il prend le couteau ils enlèvent
évidemment les locaux qui il commence à
couper l'oeuf en petits carrés payés si
vous faites là mais dit je prépare mais
il n'a pas pour la pêche et pour la
pêche et du baril ils attachent à leur
deal c'est que ces conneries
les quarante ans que je pêche jamais
entendu parler de pêche à l'oeuf à
availles hibou passer à côté d'un truc
énorme et y voyez le petit bout d'os là
le petit carré vous le mettez au bout de
l'hameçon vous jeter ça un peu loin du
bord et alors la veillée avec saic est
ce que vous prenez
et ben oui ce qui est
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est un mec est dans un bar dont qui
commence à boire des coups avec le
barman et tout électriques complètement
bourré le mec et tout lui je te parie le
mec khobar le bourg et il lui dit je te
parie 20 euros que là je suis capable de
mordre mon oeil droit
bahmani libre je les prends de 20 euros
facilement et dhiba vasily sûrement oui
mais ce matin il m'a dit vas-y tu as
peur quand même
mais qu'il enlève son oeil comme ça est
il mort son oeil reste un oeil en verre
héros mais sur l'école barbusse tard il
s'est fait prendre en euros et de la
merde et tout mais qu'ils regardent
comme ça et dit je te parie 20 euros ou
que je suis capable de mordre mon oeil
gauche et efface pas possible et les
pailles pavvb le mec si la lave
il n'est pas possible et du asie j'ai
récupéré mes bras et vent mais qu'il
enlève son dentier il est mort sonne et
il m'a eu l' hyper 40 euros il
commençait à être pas bien le barman et
tout le mec qui voit qu'il n'est pas
bien il dit bon je te parie 40 euros que
je me mets à 3 mètres tu prends un verre
un shooter comme ça et je pisse dans le
shooter sans mettre une goutte à côté
ouais les mecs qui dit c'est impossible
c'est bon là je vais récupérer mes
quarante balais diot qui a 40 bat comme
çà il prend un verre de schutter le
machisme à 3 mètres comme sait comment
ça pisse et hippies partout dans le bar
partout ils ont même eu une poudrière
partout là le barman y rigole bien il
prend les 40 euros cancha et tous et ils
voient que le mec rigole en phase iv
pourquoi tu rigoles je viens de te
prendre 40 euros là il veut ce que tu
vois le mec au fond du bar là bas j'ai
parié 1000 euros avec lui que si je
pissais danton bart allez rigoler
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un couple la femme et les genres
le ligue ans à l'hôpital c'est son vieux
tous les deux elle a des perfs elle a
des machins masquer son mari les la lui
tient la main
tout est un moment donné elle tout
simplement ce que fait mon amour mon
amour
il fait oui qu'est-ce qu'il ya qu est-ce
qu il ya l'amour de ma vie qu'est-ce qui
fait écoute j'ai une dernière chose à
tout le monde une dernière chose avant
de partir il fait tout ce que tu veux
mon amour tout ce que tu veux je ferai
tout ce que tu veux
il y fait moi l'amour une dernière fois
et si je suis moi ça va pas en fin match
est à l'hôpital qui a décrit par tous
des matchs un de mes trucs pas possibles
effets mois la manche super témoin la
mauvaise dernière fois une dernière fois
mais c'est clair la pop il prend la
porte mais une chaise il clique bloque
la porte
et puis il monte sur le lit doucement
avec beaucoup de tendresse il commence à
faire l'amour avec sa femme à cela et un
rouge qui monte aux joues et les addicts
au milieu de plus en plus heureuse c'est
merveilleux il faut la moss est sublime
c'est extraordinaire matin et ça se
termine en apothéose et les là en pleine
forme est là les perfs elle balance même
si je sais qu'elle déchire le vase elle
fait via un cierge en pleine forme et
lui reste sur le lien en laminant l'amf
est question à mon amour et c'est quand
je pense que j'ai bu sovema m
[Rires]
mais je prends amis c'est le mec qui
téléphonent au commissariat il dit pour
ma femme qui avait disparu
vous pouvez arrêter recherche et le fric
10e allait rentrer et dit non j'ai
réfléchi
avec sa femme qui est enceinte elle ma
vie coûte cher et je veux manger du
poisson mais je n'ai pas le poisson de
lidl je veux aller pêcher le poisson il
y va le mec n'a jamais été à la pêche
ils rentrent à qui voit mais dit [ __ ]
tout est glacée il fait un trou il met
sa canne à pêche et elle entend y a pas
de poisson ici et en bon dieu merci il
va elle fait un deuxième trou il met sa
canapé sur vous à l'udc a pas de poisson
ici c'est mon dieu merci le chili c'est
pas dieu c'est le directeur de la
patinoire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]